yes hello dr. Wallach thank you for all
that you do you're a great wedding well
you're very gracious thank you how can
we help you
well we're here in Maryland and um I
have a mom who is 87 years old and I had
been working with dr. Stephanie and we
started her on a cleanse which she
completed and then she's on several
remedies that are like 30-day remedies
and dr. Stephanie pointed me in your
direction I'm sorry I missed you while
you were here mm-hmm I wasn't able to
come so what happened was my mom was on
and off of meds for cholesterol heart
for years and she developed tinnitus and
Alzheimer's and well that's what she was
diagnosed with and then my sister had
her place somewhere and they you know
pretty much made her take the milk and
hot shooting works okay let's stop there
how much does she weigh she is about 130
pounds okay condition is okay to shake
five foot okay does she have public
pressure diabetes arthritis
so so she has recently we got a CT scan
because they were unable to get an MRI
and they said that she has microvascular
is chemin de z z-- your brand um an
apparent yes yes yes and apparently that
could be you know tied together with the
tinnitus and Alzheimer's and she has had
afib for some number of years okay we
already know mm-hmm the afib oh yeah
it's not a heart problem you have a
heart symptoms there's not a heart
problem
let's go with this there's a lot you
know to deal with for an 87 year old gal
so let's start
and sure mean what's Martha's mom's
basic underlying problems here
well the underlying problem obviously is
she's got a gluten intolerance she needs
to clean up her diet no wheat barley rye
oats no friend okay and what causes
native is it a heart problem what's
going on with Asia no it's a mechanical
problem the cartilage between the
vertebrae are missing and has squeezing
the nerve that goes in there are getting
thinner or shrinking yeah and I bet if
you measure your mom Martha Martha your
mom may be shrunk an inch or so and
that's what's causing the Haytham
because HR says the vertebrae getting
closer together smashing the roots of
the nerves and actually control the
heart rate and rhythm and so forth okay
Charmaine yes for her issues what's what
I would get her on would be because I
like the healthy brain and heart pack
first
a lot of her issues and I would add the
gluco gel for the afib yes yeah change
it for the issue with the irregular
heartbeat I would yeah which is
secondary to it's actually a back
problem as opposed to a heart problem
after years of her thumb they'll run
five hundred thousand dollars for the
cardiovascular these but ash is really a
back from a tube and then also what
would you add to her program to support
healthy blood pressure and blood flows
or blockers so she does have some blood
vessel problems in her brain why would
get her for blood flow I would get
around the ultimate daily classic yep
ultimate daily classic that's going to
support a healthy blood flows through
blocked arteries support healthy blood
pressure also passing I never take three
of those twice a day or two three times
a day for total six a day that's two
bottles a month and then let's see here
I'm really disturbed about her being on
cholesterol-lowering medication because
that contributes to and can be the cause
of al-harazi's
of course there's senile dementia which
is kind of liver spots and age spots in
the brain then there's Sebastian
dementia which you may have but also
Alton disease is a deficiency of what
nutrient I'm really going to try and add
this nutrient to the the list of
essential nutrients so be 91 what does
that virginities get
it's a deficiency of cholesterol yeah of
course
doctors demonized cholesterol so the
Procter & Gamble could sell Crisco of
you know back in the forties and fifties
is one of those things were here's you
know a marketing idea that went bad
because cholesterol deficiency causes
low t edy menopause at age 30 and of
course alzheimers disease which is a
lack of the myelin the white min or the
brain which makes up 75 percent of your
brain weight and the white matter the
brain is almost unheard percent what
charmaine cholesterol yeah cholesterol
when it goes away the naked nerve fibers
farm was called the nerve tangles these
nerve tangles are the classic symptom
and pathological sign color called a
Pathak demonic lesion okay when you see
nerve tangles you need to go any farther
you don't need to read the clinical
records you know that that person in
life had Allan summers disease and of
course these things are all preventable
these things you can give the body the
raw materials give your genes DNA RNA
and telomeres of raw materials and your
body can heal itself and that's why I
want you to get the hold of the book
epigenetics the deaths of these eggs are
is the transmission and maximize your
ability to heal yourself and heal the
people you love